Avec toute l'inquiétude légitime pour le SIDA et la grippe aviaire --
et nous en entendrons parler par
le brillant Docteur Brillant plus tard dans la journée --
je veux vous parler de l'autre pandémie, ce sont
les maladies cardiovasculaires, le diabète, l'hypertension --
qui sont toutes évitables pour
au moins 95% des gens,
en changeant simplement de régime alimentaire et de mode de vie.
Ce qui se passe, c'est qu'une mondiallisation
des maladies se met en place, que les gens
commencent à manger comme nous, et vivre comme nous,
et mourir comme nous. Et en une génération, par exemple,
l'Asie est passée de détenteur des plus faibles taux de
maladies cardiaques, et d'obésité, et de diabète,
à l'un des plus élevés. Et en Afrique, les maladies cardiovasculaires
sont la cause d'autant de décès que le VIH et le SIDA
dans la plupart des pays.
Aussi nous avons une fenêtre décisive d'opportunité
pour faire une différence importante qui puisse
avoir un effet sur les vies de millions de gens littéralement,
et de pratiquer une médecine préventive
à l'échelle mondiale.
Les maladies des vaisseaux sanguins et du coeur tuent
toujours plus de gens -- pas seulement dans ce pays mais aussi
dans le monde entier -- que tout le reste combiné, et pourtant
on peut les prévenir pour presque tout le monde.
Elles sont non seulement évitables, mais elles
sont en fait réversibles. Et pendant les 29 dernières années
nous avons été en mesure de le démontrer en changeant simplement
régime et mode de vie, en utilisant des mesures très sophistiquées,
coûteuses et ultramodernes pour prouver à quel point
ces intervention très simples et très peu sophistiquées
peuvent être puissantes. Une artériographie
quantitative, avant et après un an, et
des scintigraphies cardiaques en TEP.
Nous avons montré il y a quelques mois -- nous avons publié
la première étude démontrant qu'on peut effectivement arrêter
ou renverser la progression du cancer de la prostate
en faisant des changements de régime et de mode de vie, et
obtenir une régression de 70% de la croissance de la tumeur, ou une inhibition
de la croissance de la tumeur, comparé à seulement 9 %
pour le groupe de contrôle.
Et sur la spectroscopie IRM et RM ici,
l'activité de la tumeur de la prostate est marquée en rouge --
vous pouvez voir qu'elle diminue après un an.
Et puis il y a à présent une épidémie d'obésité. Deux tiers
des adultes et 15% des enfants. Ce qui m'inquiète vraiment
c'est que le diabète a progressé de 70%
ces 10 dernières années, et c'est peut-être la première
génération dans laquelle nos enfants vivent une vie plus courte
que nous. C'est pitoyable,
et c'est évitable.
Ces chiffres ne sont pas des résultats d'élections
ce sont des gens -- le nombre de gens qui sont obèses
par état, en commençant en 1985, 86, 87
ce sont les relevés du site du Centre pour la prévention et le contrôle des maladies -- 88,89,90,91
et vous voyez une nouvelle catégorie -- 92,93,94,95,96,
97, 98, 99, 2000, 2001 -- ça empire.
D'une certaine manière, nous régressons.
Et que pouvons nous y faire? Et bien, vous savez,
le régime que nous avons trouvé qui peut renverser
les maladies cardiaques et le cancer est le régime asiatique.
Mais les gens en Asie commencent à manger comme nous
c'est pour cela qu'ils commencent à être malades
comme nous le sommes.
Donc, j'ai travaillé avec beaucoup des grandes compagnies
alimentaires. Ils peuvent rendre amusants, sexys, branchés
et croustillants et pratiques à manger des aliments plus sains
par exemple -- je préside les comités consultatifs de McDonald,
PepsiCo et ConAgra et Safeway et bientôt
Del Monte, et ils trouvent que c'est bon
pour les affaires.
Les salades que vous voyez chez McDonald sont
le résultat de ce travail -- ils vont lancer une salade asiatique.
Chez Pepsi, deux tiers de la croissance de leur revenu
est le résultat de leurs meilleurs aliments.
Et donc si nous pouvons faire ça, alors nous pouvons
libérer des ressources pour acheter des médicaments dont on a
vraiment besoin pour traiter le SIDA et le VIH et la malaria
et la prévention de la grippe aviaire. Merci.